Peter Brown here with a gamespot news
update today Microsoft announced that
the Xbox one is launching in japan on
September fourth and revealed a list of
games that will be available at launch
gamers in Japan will be able to pick up
fort sub motorsport 5 kinect sports
rivals sunset overdrive dead rising 3
rise son of rome and a new halo game
Square Enix is also announce table
published called duty ghosts Tomb Raider
thief and murdered soul suspect in Japan
48 companies have signed up to release
games for xbox one in Japan Sony's
PlayStation 4 has been available in
japan since februari 22nd historically
the Xbox platform has not done well in
Japan but ahead of Xbox Phil Spencer has
not given up hope for success in the
region he said it's critical for us in
the industry that we continue to invest
there and see great games come out
September will also see the arrival of
Xbox one to twenty five other regions
including many European countries no
pricing information has been released
about the xbox one in these regions but
when it comes up stay tuned gamespot com
for more information